being a comedian all our friends are
comedians and we talk to each other in a
very special way right i.e like we're
super mean to each other like most
people think we're mean to we'll be like
hey dick like what's up
we talk to each other like that and then
i feel like i got like became like a
boss in a professional work environment
and i was talking to people like that
yeah and i was just like getting letters
from human resources every day i was
like hey dick what's up and this like 45
year old man with like a degree in like
communications and like a graduate yeah
the family's like
you yeah
you can't call the head of cbs like hey
old sag nuts what's up
what's up hooker what's up poker yeah
you can't do that no i get that a lot do
you feel like you're a good boss well i
have the same problem actually they do
dress me yeah as you know yeah and
sometimes they're dressing and they're
fiddling there's a lot of you can't i
don't i don't know i don't want your
weird no no it's mountain valley really
see i'm like i'm like i'm from the hood
i'm like if there's something free you
take it you know but i don't know if
this is real water is that a hood thing
i will no i just feel like on talk shows
there's always like prop water sure and
i feel like you know
i don't know if i should drink it but
the hood is more about caching checks
and
see this is why comedians shouldn't be
allowed on television no right we say
things that are just like ridiculous we
say things that only other comedians i
agree yeah that's what i was going to
tell you they dressed me yeah and
instead of being kind of coy i'll just
tell my wardrobe person alicia i'll be
like you touching my dick
you can't i know i'm the boss i could be
sued
no but and alicia goes home and she's
just like i don't know my 30 year old
boss told me i was touching his dick
today like you're so many people's boss
i know is that weird
can you imagine
can you imagine if dennis the menace was
like basically
giving you order it's just weird to be
someone's boss yeah we're basically like
just jerks yeah i know you know i could
never fire someone is what
it's not you wouldn't believe me it's
horrible
get out of here okay
gotcha
still kind of thinking about your
panties
i'm wearing good ones i really i really
brought it for you today i know i
noticed i really i'm really trying here
i could describe them with an accuracy
that would creep you out
what if i told you i'm not wearing any i
would be like you have a very ornate
vagina
oh god you'd have to call my brother and
be like bro i gotta delete the episode
from mom's tivo
you